this clearly has to help company
countries that bring in oil like Europe
and it has to help the United States
over time and the consumer sec the last
time I looked on a map was 71 percent of
the gdp the consumers got a great
balance sheet jobs are rising wages are
going up and the combination of wages
jobs confidence and every day you're
feeling good when you go to the pump
this is good what a jumble for
Washington Sheila barony and I think of
the lack of energy policy yeah he's
American Renaissance coming around yet
now it's like well okay you get every
interview that I do I think of Tom Petri
of ptree partners he's adamant that
America will be fine with oil in the
vicinity of where we are right now well
I think I think we've inadvertently
struck on a reasonably good policy and
we are we are going towards
self-sufficiency and I think net net
these lower oil prices energy prices are
good for the economy middle-class
workers have been squeezed wages have
been stagnating they're finally going up
a bit but get expenses down and gasoline
certainly for working men and women is a
big part of the part of the household
budget I think that's good it increases
their spending power to help the economy
so I think like both of you said the
good is unambiguously good and that is
this is a massive tax cut the equivalent
of a massive tax cut to people who
really need it and I don't think that
there should be any doubt that this will
result in higher GDP growth in the oil
importing countries but there's the bad
and the ugly the bad is this is going to
discourage future investments in energy
and this maybe you will a repeat of 97
98 96 97 97 98 where you get lower
investment in alternative energy because
all prices so low and then there's the
ugly bit and the ugly pet will take us
somewhere that I know you want to go
later on was it real politics it makes
Russia a massive wall card for the
global economy let's stay in the u.s.
right now Sara Lee krawczyk when you
start to see these curves what I call
quadratics what is it signaled to you
well as Muhammad said it's it's an
unambiguous good for the consumer and
then the question is what the consumer
does with that tax cut is you were
saying do they go out and spend it right
the seventy percent of GDP that's
consumer spending does that really
powers through if we want to get back to
the banks
go into traders you know what you don't
know is who's sitting on some potential
loss out there which again the banks
remain quite leveraged we could see some
pop here at the end of the year which
could have probably a limited but
certainly have an impact